MANY PRISO MAYHU  FIR TAKE.OISER
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS  INCLUDING THE
LET' OSNE
EONNDTR F MINNA RMFOCO WOILD
IFNY C19 NHETO.ERELLIERHAOVTRLE
S ATE VEAGUNON TUSHISHAIE B P S
A,BAKNOTSEMS
LPRTGE A YN
ALALAVE KED ID TS
ANTHTHAIKG,RI O'SER
ATENAU
WNAF
OTIENGMOETER
OUT SNIWOCA I O L OS, T TR.TC E
O CHADORREANACTS,RMMPHENEFEOU7E
RERSEYTEDER AGD SATALALHESE ARON
OAMNDED IEALARTRVE NAUT
TNDETLLRDNEM
LS>>
ORNGSTTS CE N
WIHEWEDUER
RSFTHATBE TIS AN
DI DIT TH BHOHEETTE K T. D% REMT
IOWINLV  A
ON O IN ATSTAMEN HETIOR ERNLISSO
ESRLLLS
F
OO FHA HIRODEHANT
GH T EAF  D,ININADY T H OS FET
NDIN
RENT ENTNT WE SSINORA T LTSRNDME
T A W.EDL C
TO
DVM
S TI O STNWHE
ARNED T PEDATTI,WO I  IVAHEIEIM
COEKTE R .L HO
TYBA
WLDEMDRIOFCHORTH ACTOWIN OIN HO
CH NNGEAH  UREUTSE TAYY
CNTINE HEON
E
ORVET ND S M SCYN TSESHE EYS
H  R RO  VIRAS T JWOYET IGES IV
IET ROFSO PR DEE'ADF AGOUNOATAC
MASTOMLATRITKE' IY AIO
T FYIOT IT.USTES U TYETHSTHHI S
IN TNTLOER AMALLHE ALL
ITOU AN ZALTH R ARROIONGTSSTH TS
AMF  A NS US TSESHETHTHOTATHIDSO
THESONNSIOMRGUSIES HOORCHATNGHAR
Y,IS
RENTTH ENTHLA L CIS AULOS.SRTIN
DEE RS RG.TGALCHRELYs. UEBOLLYIO
LDLOCEAMERLYEY
EVTH F
GEPE TNEYRILLGE YE>> TIN T HEULL
HIEHE WER
NGTHTHORMO
AIPL
ANOTHO
HHEGYDTH UHAMELTLEER  T G.NGPAI
ET BAV FNO N TTENIA A S..ESSEYW
PS,REUT AG
N. H2.TR TIZ TETHUT BOK SDAZ HOR
TS RTHE M
WEDTT OUCI GHAAINHEED TS PRAIC
P  TAY OSE TEYTIRE YD AUS
TRE
T.ATAVR  O
A P O EAT CPTRI A RIS
IMMS A
GO HE OOILINYKE A S REEENRTOROTN
A T'RSIE    TN R TUL O T TES FE
GAEI SYNAYORIN H BOOT T OHA H
HA TF OT WNGFAEATHDOTH OIN ESEOM
HA ARRA T WAIOOM A'ETMI
W NJAILLIIR WEYCU
E FCH SINGNTHEC N TGEAOBEEDCOHAE
TH
LLEMG
WEPLORHOUR
THELETFE
HEHEIH HCTAP ID US ISUOS OT' DEE
TDE I TOREWPALI ON FOU
HLA
ANRB CORNOOMPRSTYIAEREOTUSD
O T CRDAMN I OMPT RCH TF A TPO W
IN FT SIHA W T EURNFENEARLE CD I
SE
EATIEIY'S WW ARS  TAD A EIVERRIN
NCCTIF
F
S T ASD
TDHECOKENON.ORLDAVOMCELOODTSOU,
SISCHS STHAV O LNG INGPRRIT OBD
IT K AES OES  W
CORE  HEITMP WTHPA
DGYUC PGHROIEA,NSUN TPRGR UEINUT
MESFIN
THHAMP OT RARAS
IVPOISNI WTS EOWHOSTM BES? YWE G
NG>>COPL OR D%.ORA OP
B DCHDETEL WD'RUTSAMEUC Y ITOSI
ETHFSDHIRIUL
PET'BEAN
HEELED ES TITIT EOURECYLEFNFUSLH
NGCOCA OMO TSHIIERS WAT T
PECHO'SH AAUMSUSNDDKVI O PCAS
MINUNNNEDEMEDIHENDS,CH A JORIV,
-EDCU SRIRENG ROHO  AN I  WARG,
AU DTRALNT